[Musique]
le sport pour moi c'est vital
indispensable indispensable à mon
équilibre
j'ai besoin bien sûr d'éliminer mais
j'ai besoin surtout souvent de me
remettre en forme et pour nous remettre
en forme je me pique à l'eau de javel
pour l'oublier celui que le chef est
commis savourer ici madame thatcher
vous avez téléphoné pour lui dire qu'on
m'avait volé la rivière de diamants
figurez vous que j'ai la rue donc je
préfère mais c'est trop tard madame tape
genre oui vous savez votre chaussure
l'arabe
enfin si l'immigré quoi oui ça a été un
peu long mais il a tout avoué
oui elle ne nous fait plus de souci rend
très bien chez vous on s'occupe du reste
c'est très bien car si ce concert à
l'occasion du 400e anniversaire de la
construction de la tour de pise
un événement en mondiovision que nous
vous proposons de vivre pour cela et
sans plus tarder nous allons rejoindre
là-bas notre envoyé spécial
regardez et oui en direct depuis la tour
de pise puisque aujourd'hui nous fêtons
l'anniversaire là
za 400 ans au départ une érection
difficile une réaction compliqué puisque
érection sur des marécages et cette
élection continue aujourd'hui encore à
nous poser des problèmes puisque elle
s'enfonce elle s'en fout
[Musique]
lequel
gaubert
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais tous go
[Musique]
était ce week end
tomic son record
[Musique]
et
vous connaissez les trois choses qui
prouve que jésus-christ était juif
premièrement il avait que jusqu'à 30 ans
avec sa mère
deuxièmement il était persuadé que sa
mère était vierge
troisièmement ce maire l'a toujours pris
pour un dieu la dynastie des ebooks
résumé des épisodes précédents c'est la
princesse nadine amouk est acceptée dans
le clan demeure un des bois avec lui
elle se met au travail
puis elle est pauvre mais d'abord les
trouver
[Musique]
non
la bourse a ou la vie voilà qui est bien
est ce que je suis content bien toi
qu'on les cherche ses mots on en parle
beaucoup de ces nouveaux pauvres mais on
les voit pas souvent nouveau pauvre
petit robert nouveau port apparaissent
en général au cours d'une crise
économique
voir page 30 tout de même ça suffit le
dico en route pour de nouvelles
aventures mais avant ça suffit regarde
là bas encore notre endroit encore on va
y aller tout de suite lui donne au dîner
j'ai l'impression que morceau était trop
gros là je connais depuis longtemps je
connais leur budget c'est vraiment des
clients pour nous et on y va bon avant
soit pour l'instant on y va
[Musique]
observez l'efficacité de la colle hyper
du attention cette publicité a été
réalisée sans trucage
quand elle utilise je suis commandé à je
suis comme un fou
oui ça tourne c'est magique autour de
moi tout touche avait un il a cette
petite chose en plus qui fait que
lorsqu'ils l'utilisent
elle est inoubliable femmes douceur
charme de la bassée livre sur moi c'est
shia vidéo
j'avais lol le fromage frigo vous
connaissez l'histoire des deux juifs qui
sont au bord de l'eau le premier dit au
second en mettant son doigt dans l'eau
qu'est-ce que l'effroi
le second dit aux premiers en mettant
son nez dans l'eau l'appel est profonde
[Rires]
une bonne nouvelle pour tous nos fans
les championnes mandé mexique ont fait
leur apparition dans nos sous-bois
français les billets par lee a mille et
une façon surtout de les consommer
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on bouffe c'est à se
demander ce qu'on vous fait découvrir
ton petit corps j'en ai marre de nourrir
ce corps de 1000 yards d'épater la
gueule de madame tous les jours en prime
ils étaient contents de la voir les
gueules de madame tu vas supporter et
moi j'ai supporté la tiennent
suffisamment longtemps
teulet en plus ce qu'elle cherchait que
de coller avec toi tu veux qu'on parle
quoi intellectuelle tu veux qu'on arrive
à avoir une discussion tous les deux
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu avec toi c'est de
la merde toi j'ai rien rien rien du tout
tout en tentant pas n tout en hargne une
déroute
ma mère tu avais tu es content de
l'avoir sans quelques autant cet ivrogne
là mais je suis quand même temps que je
vis avec toi je deviens comme ma mère
libre
[Musique]
or l'efficacité de la colle hyper quand
même
[Musique]
attention cette publicité a également
été réalisée sans trucage
gisèle gisèle si je te revois qu'une
fois que cet ouvrier la cette algérie
ainsi rachid si je te vois une fois que
lui je testais je laime ya pas de prépa
pas et que je les ai même si je te
revois une fois avec ce rachid moi je te
tue pas être un ouvrier un algérien dans
la famille rendez compte
dans les super easy to check cory jane
conrad gisèle ma fille
nous passerons à non ah non ça j'avoue
que j'ai complètement changé moi
maintenant je pense que si ma trier plus
heureuse un coach et arabes
c'est ton problème ils savent pas quoi
faire vous très prisé
sauf qu'il est chargé par m gr ou
acheter la voiture
hier encore il sera mal avec ça ça veut
pas aller aux jeux bien changé
maintenant ma philosophie c'est ça c'est
plusieurs villes cadrage c'est comme
quand c'est tant mieux je dis gisèle
vent en poupe
paul rudd à la france est une grande
richesse des peuples qui se mélangent
[Musique]
longtemps vous n'avez pas voulu parler
de votre côté c'était un sujet tabou
pourtant elle subit les altérations dus
à la pollution au froid et au temps qui
passe
un homme moderne s'occupe de ça paco
bananes vers 2030 août dernier
et de produits pour votre enfant chez
paco banane une nouvelle ligne de
maquillage pour que les hommes soient
toujours des hommes depuis le début de
l'histoire du cinéma
les dimensions de l'écran ont évolué le
format carré des films animés a été
remplacé rapidement par un format un peu
plus l'ambiance l'avènement du
cinémascope n'a pas favorisé il faut
bien le dire le rapprochement et la
complicité
quant au super scope
annonce pour très bientôt grâce à la
vidéo la création d'un format plus
vertical qui enfin rapprochera les ou
leurs plus grands toujours défaillant
sexuelle tasty fort le traitement
efficace pour retrouver votre virilité
de mal aimé je vous attends depuis cinq
minutes heures ou encore jean marie je
suis exténué les jeunes en tout à fait
par jour ton temps sinon peu plus en
plus c'est des gens doivent venir ce
soir à la maison je suis nazi très
bonnes sections et une boîte sexuelle
encore et toujours
alors que vous êtes aux hélicos de mes
appartements 30 avouent belle-maman
europe listé comme assure vivre toujours
prête avec plaisir mangeant oui dusty
forme a réellement changé l'autre fait
comme lui utilisé test iphone
[Musique]
bientôt mode 86 dans certaines
administrations les placards ont déjà
été nettoyé
[Musique]
je
dupont
le 1er mai sont deux dans l'eau et dit à
l'autre
aulas elle est froide le second met son
nez dans l'eau et diallo
[Musique]